[Música]
hola qué tal con el arrullo de esa
guitarra como la semana pasada con
javier rojas iniciamos nuestro programa
de hoy les habla pablo gómez barrios y
es un gran placer estar con todos
ustedes hoy en la represa cibernética
con leonora chapman y leonardo gimeno y
quizás rufo valència si llega a tiempo
estaremos presentando les este castor
cibernético de hoy viernes 9 de
noviembre en vivo y en directo por
facebook live youtube y en nuestro sitio
internet un caluroso saludo a todos los
que nos están escuchando y oyendo allá
del otro lado de la cámara sí saludos a
todos y también contamos con la compañía
hoy de quien nos arrolla en la guitarra
el quieran muchísimo de ustedes lo
conocen seguramente no más
docente guitarrista cantautor uruguayo
que se encuentra de visita en canadá y
que está ahora en este momento en
montreal vamos a conversar con él en el
transcurso del programa bienvenido numa
muchísimas gracias también es un gusto
realmente y nos acompaña también como ya
se han dado cuenta acá en la mesa de
trabajo tenemos a alejandro rumbo
uruguayo periodista también director del
museo del carnaval a mí todo lo que
dedico al carnaval me interesa
bienvenido bienvenido a radio ganada
internacional ya estar cibernético
muchas gracias de darle rienda suelta a
este castor cibernético como de
costumbre como todos los viernes
tienen ustedes alguna noticia insólita
algo inédito algo que haya llamado su
atención durante la semana la atención
una noticia que encontré él sabe lo que
es la dark web o la web profunda si hay
donde pasan cosas que es una red
alternativa como internet pero que no se
encuentra con los buscadores o comunes
y ese tipo de cosas sino que hay que
tener un navegador especial está muy
bien protegido
bueno en resulta que hay ahora anuncios
de búsqueda de trabajo para la red
oscura o la red profunda o la dark web
como le dicen y están buscando reclutar
de gente que tenga por en ortografía por
ejemplo para la gestión económica de las
páginas web y porque se está buena
ortografía en esa web profundo porque
parece que hay que hay que subir el pero
en esa web profunda no es justamente
donde se encuentran por ejemplo aquella
gente que no quiere que se sepan lo que
hace otra
de rosa nuevamente el mundo lo encuentra
justamente el pedido de trabajo por la
oferta de trabajo en realidad es para
profesionales en delitos cibernéticos
están buscando hackers están buscando
gente
criminal llamado hacía búsqueda trabajo
trabajo escasez de mano de obra no se da
sólo entre los trabajadores migrantes y
necesita para ser durables crediticios
para vender drogas para buscar toros
vacas de balas cada uno va a otra puerta
y comprar a que para que el trabajo
rinda es obvio que el mercado laboral
está un poquito tambaleante en la dar
web también asigna
buscando gente cómo encontraste esa
noticia
ahora que webmaster y te dice a lo mejor
me interesan o no en una revista
buscándolo de material para hacerla la
crónica de tecnología y encontré en una
de las revistas tecnológicas que es la
dar web está buscando ofreciendo trabajo
en realidad aunque bueno entonces para
los que estén interesados y lyon ahora
tú por tú pero también tengo una
historia dar que es una historia triste
nada que ver con lo que está comentando
a leonardo es una historia que me llamó
la atención por dos cuestiones
principalmente una es que no conocía
esta parte histórica de canadá ocurrió
hace 150 años un poco más donde en ese
en aquel momento una primera nación
llamada chilcot en columbia británica
pues en aquel entonces hace más de 150
años las primeras naciones canadienses
eran propietarios de sus tierras y se
produjo un incidente en el cual
trabajadores de los caminos
los blancos entraron ilegalmente en ese
territorio para construir caminos y hubo
enfrentamiento el pedir permiso a la
imagen por supuesto entonces hubo
enfrentamientos y los indígenas de esta
primera nación mataron a unos cuantos
trabajadores y lo triste de esta
historia es que el gobierno en aquel
entonces convocó a cinco o seis jefes de
entre ellos para negociar la paz porque
el conflicto se estaba extendiendo un
poco y una vez que los seis jefes
indígenas aceptaron negociar la paz no
no los atraparon y los ahorcan entonces
hay claro es una historia bien trágica y
ello para los indígenas ellos definían
ese conflicto como un conflicto entre
naciones para ellos era eso entonces por
primera vez el primer ministro
canadiense de crudo fue a visitar hizo
una visita oficial a la primera la
comunidad de esta primera nación en
columbia británica para pedir disculpas
públicas por lo acontecido decía porque
eso era como
estigma para esa primera nación y
entonces lo interesante de esto fue que
el jefe de esa primera nación dijo
después de que estuvieron todos
emocionados porque no sólo era la
primera vez que un primer ministro
canadiense iba a decía esa se dirigía a
esa primera nación sino que lo hizo
personalmente crudo y habló pidió perdón
a la comunidad delante de toda la gente
entonces me parece que es un hecho para
destacar lo está muy bien y no sé
ustedes yo sé que están de paso cuando
llegaron un alejandro bueno llegamos
ayer ayer a la tarde
venimos de toronto que estuve desde el
lunes estamos acá en oralidad el martes
a la madrugada dos días en toronto ahora
acá después vamos al agua y luego
volvemos a toronto bueno y no es la
primera vez que ustedes vienen a canadá
que es lo que les ha sorprendido de no
ser la primera vez que llegaron a canadá
por ejemplo a virtuales lo que nos
sorprendió ahora te puedes ahora está
todo todo pasta para arriba las calles
también podríamos llegar a la casa donde
estaba porque se cortaba casi cortaba y
veíamos pues eso nos llama la atención
mucho que tú nomás si eso eso fue muy
impactante
la ciudad patas para arriba no me fue
muy pero además encontrarnos con viejos
amigos siempre lindo y la llegada a
toronto y aquí también que nos
encontramos con uruguayos peruanos un
buen compañero peruano nos esperó y es
siempre lindo
reencontrarse con la gente no hay que
decir que en una forma parte de una
generación de artistas músicos poetas de
los años 70 en américa latina si en él
72 tuvimos que salir del país por
programa político lógicamente quedamos
prohibidos en aquella época y bueno
estuvimos 13 años de exilio en el 84
volvimos
muy bien y lo lindo digo no sé lo lindo
de esto es que justamente vienen a hacer
un homenaje a uno de los grandes de los
más grandes poetas latinoamericanos que
es daniel vigletti de eso vamos a hablar
pero yo quiero hablar de mi hecho
insólito bueno pues que me sorprendió
esta nos dice que encontré acá en radio
canadá en nuestro sitio y es de un
holandés que tiene nuestra edad no al
tipo tiene 69 años
[Música]
entonces digamos un señor de 69 años
holandés que demandó oficialmente al
gobierno que le rebajen 40 20 años a
cara
en 20 años oficialmente de su bautismo
de su fe de bautismo y que él le den
oficialmente el 49 años de edad y eso
porque dice porque la razón es dice
porque él está muy
descontento con irse al retiro y dice
que es víctima de discriminación debido
a la edad y aparte de eso que es víctima
de discriminación en amor
y esto es algo que los tribunales no
holandeses no saben cómo manejar porque
es la primera vez que le hace un pedido
parecido ahora mostrarme la foto del
señor
aunque se rebaje 30 años que se olvide
pero la idea es que la idea es que si
oficialmente tiene 49 puede encontrar
esto se puede encontrar trabajo
una novela uno nunca sabe se acaba de
unir a nosotros acá en el estudio
nuestro colega rufo valència bien
bienvenido ruffo
rufo valencia el otro colega el tercer
el del tercer ladrón
el granero del tercer mosquetero
alejandro rumbo numa moraes nuestros
invitados hoy no tienes que bien fuese
de 10 años y usted vino con el campus y
la radio de la universidad mcgill
entonces el grupo de bolivia están los
argentinos que son casi mayoritarios
pero hay la paridad porque hay un
uruguayo y un boliviano y un colombiano
dos grupos estábamos en lo de lo inédito
no sé tú que viene llegando de viaje que
te sorprendió por ello no sé si hay algo
que haya traído para atención esta
semana después esta semana sobre todo
los resultados de la elección en estados
unidos creo que
en los 30 años elección de medio mandato
de mimat estados unidos en 30 años que
vivo en grada nunca había visto tanto
interés de los canadienses la radio
pública despacho corresponsales a los
grandes y grandes a los realización
ciudades donde iba a haber importante
votación entonces explicación ado fue
los sentimos porque fue hecha la primera
vez que sentimos que era una una
votación casi local y justamente canadá
y eeuu y una frontera de 9.000
kilómetros es la frontera más larga del
mundo entonces lo que pasa ya afecta
directamente acá por ejemplo todavía no
se firmó el tratado de libre comercio el
bus usm acá y vamos a ver qué es lo que
va a pasar y una vez que los demócratas
estén con grace side y se dan bueno
hay que revisar ese acuerdo entonces hay
muchas hay muchos temas canadienses que
se disputaron en selección muy bien de
los valores canadienses y donald trump
que en alguna en alguna ocasión cuando
asumió la presidencia pensó le pasó por
la mente a montar un muro en la frontera
con canadá pero a lo mejor cuando lo
dijeron que eran 9000 kilómetros
bueno nos encontramos aquí lo que pongan
un alambrado
[Música]
y para cantar desalambrar nadie mejor
que un humano bueno regresemos a
nuestros invitados
no más alejandro cuál es el motivo de la
visita bueno mañana es muy importante
para la audiencia de mañana nomás se
presenta en casa café hay 53 15 de ruiz
club wellington en verde a partir de 19
horas en la presentación que va que va a
tener acá en montreal por lo tanto a
todos aquellos que nos quieran acompañar
va a ser un show específico como como
antes hablábamos en homenaje a viglieti
este y presentación también de ese disco
que acabamos de regalar por lo tanto
invitamos a todos los que nos quieran
acompañar mañana en la casa café esté en
la calle huele muy bien es emotivo y es
una gira que sigue por otra aguas el
jueves 15 estaremos en ottawa y el 17 en
toronto y el 22 también en toronto
cerrando esta pequeña gira por canadá en
el este de canadá o sea no van al oeste
no van a vancouver lo carga vuelta no y
esta vuelta no y tú numa entonces pues
contento de regresar
feliz a mí me encanta el frío en uruguay
hace mucho calor así que estoy feliz
pero todavía poder hacer algo muñeco
nieve algo así
sí sí es eficaz y viene de esa noche en
realidad así dice que hay probabilidad
de nieve muy fuerte
no te lo recoge después del concierto
[Música]
uruguay a un diputado indicaba que
uruguay valle de imbatido por estados
unidos cuando en estos días pidieron el
se pidió permiso al gobierno uruguayo
para 400 estadounidenses que van a
custodiar a donald trump que va a estar
en la cumbre del g20 en argentina y
bueno tendremos que invitarlo barbaridad
47 una barbaridad
uruguay canadá tienen la particularidad
que han legalizado la marihuana
países como eso por allá es que
realmente aumentó tanto el consumo de
marihuana
como siempre se dice cuando cuando
canadá estaba en campaña para legalizar
había unas voces que clamaban de que
esto iba a ser incontrolable en es que
sucedió lo mismo sucede eso en uruguay
yo no creo que es un buen ejemplo ya son
dos años tres años no yo creo que a
nivel médico sobre todo hay una yerba
mate por ejemplo la abuelita tiene una
señora muy alta caso que se tiene
variedad muy poquito no es bueno para
reumatismo me decía mi mamá cuando
cuando vi que tenía una mata de
marihuana en el patio y le digo mamá si
esta planta para que se mire que su
bueno para el reumatismo nos lo pongo en
el alcohol y me froto con el desayuno
como no fumo ni me
ningún modo ni fú ni fá pero en
diciembre estuve en holanda y yo viví
muchos años allá por eso me llamaba la
atención de mi amigo rejuvenecer
allá vi que había una increíble como se
vende y hay tiendas y todo es turismo
cuales hay un estado de eeuu colorado y
en el estado de colorado los primeros
dos años subió exponencialmente y
después bajó a los niveles normales la
novedad la gente va a comprar algunos
les gusta otros no lo siguen haciendo
otros no y en realidad muy buena normal
es lo que pasa exactamente el mismo es a
disposición del que quiere lo toma y no
por eso hay más borrachos o problemas
con alcohol desde que está legalizado de
suicidio al alcohol por ejemplo nunca
tomé he tomado vino
y esas cosas
99 grados
bueno les recuerdo que están escuchando
el castor cibernético saludos allá que
hay comentarios de leonardo de un saludo
en realidad de baldera saludo muchos
saludos del cine antonio muy buen
programa de hoy quiero compartir con
ustedes que mañana 10 de noviembre se
cumple un nuevo aniversario del
nacimiento de la prensa de san antonio
el 10 de noviembre de 1895 nació el
diario los tiempos de esa fecha hasta
ahora ha surgido mucho un medio de
comunicación en nuestra ciudad después
de poner petancourt dice saludos
cordiales a todos en colombia solo
mayelis flores también nos dice hola en
nuestras redes sociales bueno saludos a
todos saludos saludos y bueno entonces
pues vamos ahora nomás a ver con quién
nos va a desarrollar y qué tema quieres
interpretar alguna
[Música]
recuerdo una de tu patria es una canción
que canta julio jaramillo donde habla de
marihuana que presta para mis hermanos y
hermanos los hermanos
[Música]
yo tengo tantos hermanos
que no los puedo contar
en la selva y la montaña en la pampa y
en el mar
[Música]
con sus trabajos con sus sueños cada
cual
en la esperanza delante con los
recuerdos detrás
yo tengo tantos hermanos que no les
puedo contar
[Música]
no caliente
de la misma
nos va a ayudar con restos
para rezar
un horizonte abierto
[Música]
está más allá
y esa fuerza sea para buscarlo con tesón
y voluntad
parece más cerca es cuando
yo tengo tantos hermanos que no los
puedo contar
[Música]
y así seguimos andando
de soledad
y nos perdemos por el mundo nos volvemos
a encontrar
y así nos reconocemos
el lejano mirar
por la copla que nos rodeamos semillas
de invención
y así seguimos andando
por tipo de soledad
y el nosotros nuestros muertos más que
nadie
de atrás
yo tengo tantos hermanos que no los
puedo contar y una novia muy hermosa que
se llama libertad
[Música]
numa moraes y seguimos acá en los
estudios son inmortales y la edad no es
nada no te rebaje la edad que estaban
interesados
y de idea
yo no entiendo ni ya me dio gracias por
traducir me no estamos acá en el castor
cibernético y
vamos a tenemos algún mensaje por
leonardo de los internautas pero tengo
mensaje de mensaje si no me equivoco
estoy señor un comentario la población
de canadá envejece y las personas
mayores ahora superan a los niños esto
es un caso para mandar hola andaríamos
dice que buscar de la curiosos dice que
este tema es súper interesante así que
tenemos otro mensaje en este caso javier
a conocer en un gran sobre la caravana
de migrantes primeros grupos ya se ya
están llegando a méxico es una realidad
bien palpable que esta gente son
personas que durante la pobreza y la
violencia de las bandas criminales
incrustadas en el tejido social
hondureño y centroamericano además de
estar de acuerdo con las autoridades
corruptas el que diga lo que diga el
señor trump que son criminales yo creo
que está equivocado porque transitan
prácticamente con toda su familia
saludos a todos en el say desde
guadalajara méjico a poco saludos javier
que es vamos con orlando isaza vázquez
quien reacciona a la noticia de facebook
determina nuevos límites para las
publicaciones y él dice
las publicaciones tienen algún límite
para ser compartidas en los grupos a los
que uno pertenece quién toma la decisión
de bloquear al usuario y por qué cuando
se hace una apelación por bloqueos no se
recibe una respuesta se escribe correos
cero respuesta será comunicados por
parte de facebook y facebook lo único
que les interesa es que tenga ahí la
plantilla
cada persona dio 26-26 dólares por
cabeza a nivel mundial y una utilidad de
26 dólares a fiabilidad 66 imagínate los
móviles y miles de millones de dólares
que tuvo una buena idea al muchacho no
somos nosotros los que estamos cortos y
tengo acá un mensaje sobre este
reportaje que era porque olvidar hace
más inteligente
según universidad de toronto y comenta
héctor da silva dormir bien es necesario
para recordar pero a veces olvidamos los
recuerdos conflictivo
para poder dormir muy bien yo tengo acá
miles de canadienses marchan contra el
racismo en montreal y juana neves dice
que ve que es una tierra de inmigración
aquí nadie es racista que tiene que ver
el racismo además con la religión desde
siempre es tierra de inmigración pero si
se dan cuenta los únicos que nos tratan
de catalogar nos de racistas son los
musulmanes desde ahora basta están
insultando a uno de los pueblos más
acogedores del mundo
soy portuguesa nació en lisboa y me
integré gentes musulmanas dejen de vivir
tras su cortina de humo aprendan a amar
su tierra y sus libertades y si no
regresen a casa es el comentario de
juana neves que me parece un poco duro y
ser perfecto si con respecto a los
musulmanes porque bueno
es cierto que hay una atención no
en este momento con respecto a los
musulmanes no sólo aquí en canadá sino
también en eeuu un poco y bueno me
parece que sí que es demasiado
sería bueno que tiene se le pida de
portugal lisboa coimbra son todas
ciudades que tuvieron sus mejores
momentos de su historia
o se inculto intelectualmente cuando los
los árabes estaban esa parte era el
califato de córdoba que controlaba
españa y también portugal y la
arquitectura que todavía se puede ver la
alfama en portugal en lisboa son lugares
fantásticos entonces había que recuperar
también las partes de la historia claro
hay que salir un poco de los recovecos
en los que nos encontramos porque a los
portugueses los griegos los italianos
son una inmigración las primeras horas
de inmigración es que llegaron al
principio que se integraron como se
integraron se integraron muy bien y no
habían estos roces que hay ahora no
entonces pues fueron muy bien acogidos y
los
es muy bien pero pues tampoco hay que
pensar que los que no lo que sufren de
alguna forma de segregación tienen que
regresarse a su casa si con eso no nos
volvemos todos había una caricatura que
decía justamente américa de norte y
refiriéndose a eeuu y quizá en este caso
también a este lado de la frontera en
que esta parte del mundo es el único
lugar en que los inmigrantes insultan a
otros inmigrantes llamándoles
inmigrantes
así es alejandro se quiero conversar
contigo y que no nos hables un poco de
este museo del carnaval tú eres el
director del museo del carnaval que
entre otras cosas tiene entre otros
proyectos me imagino y guinle y muy
rápido tiene uno muy particular que me
gustó mucho háblanos del museo porfa
bueno mucho carnaval fue creado hace ya
12 años cumplimos ahora en noviembre y
fue creado en el marco de una teoría que
es la nueva museología por eso voy a
visitar
el ecomuseo pues lo sé cómo se
canadiense fueron vanguardia en sus años
de la nueva museología y cuando se
piensa en ese museo de carnaval el
carnaval uruguayo es el más largo del
mundo que dura 45 45 días y nosotros
decimos que dura todo el año porque es
verdad que dura todo el año por cómo
termina el carnaval ya empieza el otro
porque hay varias el largo de contar
pero claro ahí este carnaval de niños
hay que murga joven etcétera c3 va
transcurriendo y bueno y vamos pasar en
el caso nuestro cuando inauguramos
en tomamos la nueva museología y que él
básicamente y groseramente lo que habla
es que el museo no tiene que ser
aquellos viejos vetusto y elitista donde
uno va a haber determinado elemento
conservado dice voy como adorar eso sino
que tiene que tener un contacto directo
con la comunidad nosotros eso lo tomamos
tenemos un departamento de inicio se
llama relacionamiento con la comunidad
trabajamos en 18 barrio montevideo
rescatando una tradición perdida por los
años 50-60 que es la decoración de
escenario en uruguay hay escenarios
populares en distintos barrios que es
los vecinos voluntariamente son los que
lo gestionan y la intendencia de
montevideo en este caso lo que hace es
llevar conjuntos pagos por la
intendencia y el lo que se gana de eso
se reinvierte en el barrio en distintas
merendero en lo que es mejorar el local
etcétera etcétera o sea que no vuelve
esa plata que se gana a la intendencia
sino que esa queda en el barrio y los
vecinos son los que voluntariamente
realizan en esos barrios nosotros la
decoración escenario era fundamental en
los años 50 porque te a través de
escenografías te contaban cosas pasaba
algo por ejemplo toda la marihuana que
pasó se venía hablando hace tiempo y
este y un tablado hizo una hoja de
marihuana con un jamaiquino tirado
fumando y por otro lado hizo el pepe
mujica con un ayer conserva hierba
mantener este que en ese momento estaba
carísima entonces como que la marihuana
iba a ser barata y la observaba acercar
jugando con eso pero qué quieres quiero
decir que desde ese el escenario que
parte del espectáculo se dicen cosas se
homenajean gente etcétera otro rubro que
tenemos es el trabajo en cárceles que es
muy interesante en la cárcel de mujeres
ya sé bueno hicimos carros alegóricos
ahora estamos particularmente hace tres
años enfocado en tres talleres uno de
maquillaje uno vestuario y una
escenografía y a través de escenografía
también tenemos unos módulos que son de
electricidad y soldadura todo con la
excusa del carnaval pero se le da
elemento a la privada libertad para que
aprenda un oficio para que se integren
para a través o exigimos puntualidad
exigimos respeto a ese equipo de trabajo
en grupo exigimos etcétera etcétera
etcétera a través de nuestro tallerista
y al finalizar éste tiene un diploma que
si cumplen con el 80 por ciento la
civilidad sería un diploma que ese
diploma al salir
tiene una validez a través del museo de
carnaval e interesante también que
hacemos pasantías o sea que dentro de la
cárcel o fuera la cárcel
pagamos para que hagan determinados
trabajos en carnaval o sea básicamente
estamos aquí está un fuente de trabajo
también si porque nosotros vimos que no
alcanzaba con enseñar un oficio adentro
sino que salir salen igual existe la
posibilidad es algo claro porque bueno
en señas pero pues quien no toma afuera
la entonces bueno lo que hacemos a
carnaval a través de las murgas en
uruguay hay cinco clases de los
periodistas humoristas los luego los la
revista y las murgas las murgas que te
gusta grado dejaron un cd para que lo
compartan con la audiencia ustedes acá
de las nulas de este año es lo más
digamos popular y ellos precisan hacer
sus trajes sus gorros 7 a su vestimenta
y la hacemos a través de las presas
ahora por ejemplo una murga joven hizo
todo todo el vestuario que a veces se
cambia en el mismo en la misma actuación
se cambian dos o tres veces de vestuario
bueno se hicieron en adentro de la
cárcel empiece bueno eso les da primero
aprenden pero también les da un vínculo
con esa murga joven
y estamos desmitificando también a que
el tema del preso y el de no preso y si
queremos realmente que alguien se
rehabilite bueno estás enseñando después
de la manera en la reinserción social
que es fundamental pues mira este se
está llevando a cabo comenzó ayer acá en
montreal los encuentros internacionales
del documental de montreal y estaba
entrevistando entrevista esta semana a
la directora de ese de esos encuentros y
hay un jurado me llama la atención esto
de la cárcel porque hay un jurado ellas
trabajan con la cárcel de mujeres de
joliet sí entonces hay un jurado de
detenidas que se escogen seis mujeres
detenidas cada año cambia esta es la
benc la vigésima primera edición de los
del festival y estas mujeres que están
en la cárcel pues miran las películas y
y se da el premio de las detenidas en el
marco del festival y me decía en
entrevista la directora que es
justamente para eso para que ya desde ya
irlas preparando es una forma de
reinserción social y de esa forma pues
cuando salen de ahí al menos no están
tan aisladas de lo que está pasando en
el mundo no porque estamos por
intermedio del cine están viendo qué es
lo que sucede en el mundo así que bueno
me parece interesante y sigo creyendo
que es muy interesante ese ese proyecto
que ustedes tienen nosotros animo a
visitar al alcalde como se deduce
ormonde el vamos a ir el lunes a visitar
lo que también nos interesa que gestión
se hace como si todas esas cosas no nos
re interesan para ver si nosotros
estamos en condiciones de hacerlo en el
rumbo juzgado no es bueno intercambiar
siempre importa bueno en el tiempo pasa
siempre como agua entre los dedos pnüma
a ver qué que que nos quieres
interpretar no es lindísimo también lo
que están haciendo en el interior del
país
hay otro carnaval uruguay chicos tenemos
la realidad que tenemos contra argentina
[Música]
daniel viglieti hizo muchas
musicalizaciones también sobre poemas de
poetas
universales como se ser vallejo lo que
se a rafael alberti y poetas uruguayos
desde que éramos niños grises aprendimos
es gordito gurisito claro y esta es una
musicalización del sobre una muy querida
poeta nuestra decirse maya sin duda la
principal poeta viva nuestra querida en
tacuarembó mi poder y fue profesora mía
también otra buscando
[Música]
por detrás de mi voz
escucha escucha otra buscando
[Música]
viene de atrás o de lejos
viene de sepultada
pocas me ganó
dicen que no están muertos escucha los
escucha mientras se alza la voz que los
recuerda y canta escucha escucha y otra
buscando
dicen que ahora viven en tu mirada
sostengo con tus ojos con tus palabras
sostén los con tu vida que no se pierden
que no se caigan te escucha escucha otra
buscan
no son solo memoria son vida abierta
y no hay ancha son caminos que empieza
cantando conmigo conmigo cantar
aunque no están muertos escuchando su
escucha mientras se alza la voz que lo
recuerda y canta
cantan conmigo
cantar
solo memoria son
está bien
un camino que empieza y que no
conmigo
[Música]
cantando
conmigo con mi boca
[Música]
en otra voz canta y escuchaban a numa
moraes el concierto de mañana es todo
sobre él y tío tiene hay otro tipo de
repertorio voy a cantar canciones de
todas las épocas pero voy a poner un
acento en algunos algunas canciones de
daniela algunas que vamos a cantar
además con el público porque desalambrar
por ejemplo e inevitable que todo el
mundo se ponga a cantar
por lo menos los uruguay todo el mundo
por lo menos la gente de nuestra edad
esto se conoce porque ésta era
considerado en los años 70 canciones de
protesta todo representa esta generación
de daniel viglieti eran los veinteañeros
los bebés los que realmente escuchábamos
íbamos a los conciertos me preguntaba en
noma que es lo que escuchan estos
jóvenes de 20 años en el cono sur por lo
menos o en el xi qué tipo de música que
se hayan que ya no es la de protesta
es que bueno el problema como decía a
don atahualpa
hay canciones con ruido adentro
canciones que dicen que dicen que tiene
una profundidad como está este texto
decir se maya y hay otro a otro tipo de
música más de divertimento no
ahí
claro
mucha gente que muchos jóvenes yo doy
clase en la escuela nacional de danza
división folklore es desde hace 26 años
y claro son muchachos muy jóvenes que no
conocen los antiguos cantores uruguayos
no conocen lo que pasa en latinoamérica
no tanto o lo escuchan pero no saben
quién son las operaciones diferentes son
el código con problemas diferentes pero
eso no significa que no sean militantes
ya sea ecológicos claro de la estela de
la igualdad que se o sí sí y por eso me
preguntaba si sabes qué tipo de música
escuchan escuchar lic a los
representantes por ejemplo en el rock
and roll en un momento dado si ahora más
bien es la música caribeña no con mucho
ritmo pero reggaeton el reggaeton craft
pero hay una una parte de la juventud
que está buscando nuevamente como todo
es un círculo y tuvo el verde de pronto
escuchamos y rodríguez castillos y se
viste quién es pero es el autor de la
galpón era la canción que cantaba mi
abuelo
y bueno también estoy dando un curso
sobre música latinoamericana el otro día
fue muy cómico porque
les presento gracias a la vida estaba en
chileno viajando por thriller con la
música gracias a la vida así sea una
muchachita la canción de mercedes sosa
novio no es de mercedes sosa le leí el
texto y me porfiaban que sí porque en
internet
decía que era de mercedes sosa la
versión de violeta parra popular y que
no podían creer la intensidad y la
sencillez y lo que sucedió después con
violeta y fue todo un hallazgo para ello
pasa continuamente con la música peruana
con la música argentina cuando les hablo
de salud de su pan que de sus mapas con
con bolivia con los aymaras con el paco
al danés y les hago escuchar esas
flautas increíbles
es muy interesantes y son muchachos de
20 21 22 años pero claro la gran
cantidad de muchachada van por la música
más más más ruidosa sin ruido y además
hay que decir cosas no y bueno no quiero
pasar por aguafiestas pero nos quedan
tres minutos entre el programa y las
coplas al payador perseguido si quieres
entonces les quiero agradecer a nuestro
técnico al en shabwa en la presentación
de los programas no sé si todos estamos
de acuerdo que tienen que visitar
nuestro sitio de internet para ver
cuáles son los temas que resaltamos esta
semana nuestros invitados hoy alejandro
rumbo y numa moraes vi seguro entonces
pues vamos a terminar este programa con
numa moraes que nos interpreta una
milonguita cortita una milonguita
tenemos dos minutos
lindo y más y más
lago rapidísimo puedes pasar después
pasar la dejamos grabar a dios gracias
muchas gracias
[Música]
i
y él
[Música]
no
i
a
no no
[Música]
veamos
parece que es algo forma parte de los 13
años
muchas gracias muchas gracias alejandro
fue un gran placer y un orgullo tenerlos
acá ustedes de estar ambas con nosotros
en este 14 y vernet icono yo creo que
ahí estamos de acuerdo todos nos vemos a
todos a yao